what's up everyone so a lot of hype
right now around these Avengers for
reshoots we've seen Chris Evans we've
seen Scarlett Johansson we've seen Paul
Rudd and everybody has been trying to
figure out every possible detail that we
can gather from these leaked photos that
we've seen so far even Jeremy Renner has
posted photos of him going to do
reshoots for Avengers 4 and it's
interesting because he wasn't in
infinity war at all and it's highly
speculated that he will be returning as
Ronin in Avengers 4 and speaking of
characters that were not in infinity war
but Mike return in Avengers 4 Tessa
Thompson was recently spotted with Chris
Hemsworth and we've gained a little bit
of information that leads us to believe
that Valkyrie could possibly be in
Avengers 4 just a quick reminder about
the giveaway I'm doing I'm giving away a
copy of Avengers infinity war on blu-ray
a special edition poster and some
special memorabilia from our partners at
silk and cotton all you have to do to
enter is subscribe to my channel like
this video and comment below with your
thoughts
and your favorite superhero so Tessa
Thompson and Chris Hemsworth are
currently filming men in black together
right now
while filming Chris Hemsworth took to
his Instagram story and said that they
were filming men in black in some exotic
locations he then said he was returning
to Atlanta for some Avengers for
reshoots and then him and Tessa Thompson
got on his private jet not too long
after that some photos surfaced of him
and Tessa Thompson getting off the jet
in Atlanta so what does this mean does
this mean that Valkyrie is returning in
Avengers 4 and she's doing some reshoots
in Atlanta there's lots of ways that you
can say that it makes sense for Valkyrie
to return in Avengers for the heroes
that are left are going to need all the
help they can get to figure out a way to
undo that osa snap
not to mention Thor is probably going to
want to search for his people to see who
survived Thanos a snap and now that he
has Stormbreaker and the ability to
summon the Bifrost at will it probably
won't be too hard to find them
and again with these reshoots they said
that they're not only re shooting some
scenes but they're also finishing the
movie so it's very possible and likely
that
they're changing some of the story and
remember this movie is wrapping up the
first ten years but it's also kicking
off the next phase so on screen we're
going to have our original heroes the
ones that have been here the first ten
years and some that are going to
continue to stay here probably for the
next ten years and it's very very likely
that Chris Hemsworth is going to be
playing Thor for the next handful of
years which means that Valkyries should
be around as well stay please please
alright so it would make sense for
Valkyrie to appear in Avengers 4 even if
it's just for a brief moment finished by
if Thor ends up settling Asgard on earth
it's most likely that we'll see her in
that scene and that scene would take
place at the end of the movie obviously
after they defeated Thanos and again the
Russo brothers said that they are
finishing the movie so there are a
number of ways that Valkyrie could make
her return in Avengers 4 whether that's
a small role like at the end of the
movie when a scar settles on earth or
it's to come back and help fight Thanos
I personally would love to see Valkyrie
come back to help Thor and the rest of
the heroes fight Thanos but what do you
all think do you think that Tessa
Thompson is in Atlanta for Avengers 4
reshoots and if so what role do you
think she will have in Avengers 4 let me
know your thoughts in the comments below
and again a reminder about the giveaway
if you would like to enter all you have
to do is be a subscriber like this video
and comment below with your thoughts
and your favorite superhero thank you so
much for watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]
you